bonjour et bienvenue pour ce live sur
scène ici à montpellier j'aimerais
aujourd'hui parler d'une citation de et
les erreurs guide cosmique et à l'un des
auteurs du blog des swarmites avec
laquelle il ya un bouquin qui est sorti
plutôt qu' une compilation de ses
billets de blogs qui s'appelle watchmen
électif et itunes 10 est l'une des
citations et beaucoup de citations assez
amusante récurrentes
est-ce qu'il y en a une dont j'en
reparle aujourd'hui c'est celle qui dit
que l'inversé critiquer n'est pas
d'intelligence et je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très important à
comprendre surtout lorsqu'on aime
débattre parce que c'est parce que
quelque chose qui est beaucoup sur
twitter avoir des positions et défendre
leurs positions et c'est quelque chose
assez récurrent assez naturel est le
gros point c'est que souvent lorsqu'on
va défendre une position
une façon de faire notamment sur twitter
c'est de chercher à ridiculiser les
arguments du côté opposé
et pour ce faire malheureusement ce qui
est fait souvent c'est que parce que
c'est plus facile à faire c'est de
choisir les plus mauvais argument du
côté opposé et d'essayer de les
ridiculiser de se moquer de ces
arguments du côté opposé
et je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement mal extrêmement nuisible
qui a des conséquences très très
mauvaise et très peu désirable tout
point de vue du coût message principal
de cette vidéo c'est si vous avez
tendance à faire ça vous aimez moquer
publiquement des arguments idiot tu
colloque du composé ou votre s'ajuster
dios et je pense qu'on pourrait que vous
arrêtez pas ce que vaut ce que ça vaut
mais voilà ses sous non pas par de
gaulle alors ce genre de façon de faire
c'est malheureusement quelque chose que
je vois beaucoup chez pas de gens que
j'admire votre sens du tueur typiquement
qui on parle de sujets de société qui
sont dits délicat difficile et sur
lesquels va voir un avis informés
comment il ya beaucoup de d'études
scientifiques qui peuvent contribuer à
mieux structurer réflexion je pense
typiquement des sujets super tocci comme
le réchauffement climatique la
vaccination
loblaw tati sur tous ces sujets là il ya
beaucoup d'oppositions beaucoup
d'arguments débile à la fois des
arguments anti scientifique des villes
mais aussi des arguments scientifiques
c'est débile et je pense que c'est très
important si les sur le fait que rejeter
un argument débile du camp opposé ne
fait pas du tout avancé en fait les
schmilblick
ce qu'il ya des arguments à opposer des
arguments débiles de défend de tout et
n'importe quoi y compris les sciences
est malade et je trouve ça toujours très
gênante voire voilà un argument débile
pour le côté opposé à ce que j'avance
sur le côté opposé à boké cherché à
ridiculiser et je conseille toujours
dérangeant que le côté opposé
choisissent ni demain son argument le
plus débile et qu'on se met à se moquer
de suez à le partager sur twitter dans
notre peter bubble entre gens qui sont
contre cette position opposée qui aimons
nous moquer du des arguments débiles du
côté opposé
je trouve que ça c'est vraiment très
mauvais comme façon de faire pour
plusieurs raisons la première annoncée
que pour toutes les positions il y a des
arguments débiles qui vont dans cette
position est souvent quand c'est des
sujets tels chiffres des sujets de
société
et voilà on va trouver quelqu'un qui à
cette position et qu'il a du coup sortir
ses arguments débiles pour la défendre
ou d'un moment ça ça fait que rejeter un
argument débile ou se moquer d'un
commentaires youtube débiles qui défend
un telle ou telle position
en fait ça fait pas du tout avancer le
débat c'est ça sert à rien ça fait même
perdre du temps ça attire l'attention
sur quelque chose qui n'est pas
pertinent et ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
parlé beaucoup se concentrer sur des
sujets qui sont pas les sujets
importants
deuxième conséquence plus grave à mon
sens c'est le fait que du coup ça ramène
les niveaux des débats toujours plus bas
ce sur tous ces sujets il y avait
question en france vraiment à ces noms
trial assez assez enfin vraiment
intéressante et il ya vraiment de quoi
réfléchir de façon très intéressante sur
toutes ces questions et vêtu est
possible de santé ou ce que vous voulez
mais le fait qu'on soit constamment
ramener très rapidement devoir parler d'
argument débile
fait que reste au ras des pâquerettes et
on peut pas parler des choses
intéressante est obligé de se cantonner
à juste des trucs débiles et sa
globalement c'est une tendance assez
classique on a tendance à vouloir
ramener les débats à des choses
extrêmement simpliste
surtout du côté opposé et à vouloir dire
que voilà les champs et qui pense aux
côtés opposés sont forcément des gens
complètement débile tendre et
complètement irrationnel alors que
parfois la position inverse ya moyen de
les comprendre des choses plus
sophistiqués plus nuancé dans la manière
d'un petit réfléchissent et pour en
arriver là il faut absolument ne pas
commencer par ridiculiser le camp opposé
sur twitter il ya un effet des cours
plus qui est qui est assez horrible qui
fait que quand quelqu'un commence à se
moquer de quelque chose et tu vas avoir
des commentaires qui montera à brandir
pour vraiment être débile pour penser x
et y voit tout de suite que le débat ait
un revenu au niveau zéro au niveau
d'ebit était maximale et ses six étoiles
c'est c'est dommage parce qu'après on
prend l'habitude d'avoir ces débats de
niveau zéro pour tous les domaines et
ensuite une troisième raison pour
laquelle je pense que c'est vraiment mal
de partager ce genre de choses
commentaires sur youtube c'est débile
déjà je comprends les tueurs qui font ça
parce que moi j'ai pas mal envie de
faire ça mais je les fais tu entends
envie de faire ça voilà un commentaire
débile dans ma vidéo ça m'énerve parce
que c'est difficile d'être indifférents
commentaires youtube c'est à ceux qui
sont adressées directement et parfois
ils sont très très très violent et du
coup forcément un petit peu en état
émotionnel pas à l'aise on va dire pas
se rendre et du coup on a envie de dire
regardez comme intégrant ces dix villes
de partager le montrer ça à quelqu'un et
en particulier aux messages sur twitter
en fait on a envie d'avoir le soutien
aux toute notre communauté et de tous
les gens qui pensent comme nous et envie
que tout un droit qui disent ah oui
c'est vrai que c'est complètement débile
et ça ça nos très mauvais goût peu en
force et hooligans
politique c'est de se dire que il ya des
camps nous on est dans le bon camp que
les autres sont soit mauvais soit
méchant je pense que c'est vraiment une
attitude très très très récurrentes
trail nature à la vidéo qui dit que
c'est même la morale sélectionnée par
sélection naturelle et je pense qu'il
faut absolument lutter contre ça parce
que ça crée des clans sur twitter sur
partout et ça a fait clic on arrive plus
à ce communiqué y s'identifient à leur
propre camp et vous défendre chacun va
défendre son côté est souvent va le
faire de façon un peu au delà parce que
la raison pourrait autoriser et alors je
sais qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
l'utilisation du terme aux hooligans
parce que ça prouve que j'en pense que
c'est un terme trop violent et peut-être
que c'est pas le bon terme
il parlait de découpe de situations de
soldats en faveur de son pas c'était un
petit il en est là je suis là ghallef
c'est le super de ted com - à titre
personnel que ça comme vous voulez ou
guiliane mettre un soldat en faveur de
son propre camp je trouve que c'est une
position qui est extrêmement
problématique parce que fait c'est
vraiment l'état d'esprit où on a un but
qui est souvent défendre notre camp et
détruire le camp adverse et on va
utiliser uniquement de notre raison pour
atteindre cet objectif
ou alors on va y arriver par un tous les
moyens possible d'user d'arguments
complètement irrationnel s'il faut pour
x y arriver c'est ce genre d'état
d'esprit qui je pense est incroyablement
visible et malheureusement ultra
récurrent chez tout le monde dès qu'on
parle de sujets que tu le sujet en
politique n'at on doit concilier
s'identifier un quand on veut défendre
notre camp et en le défendant on utilise
tous les stratagèmes possibles des pires
stratégie c'est d'essayer de prendre ce
qu'elle peu ridicule dans le camp opposé
et de leurs besoins boké et pourquoi ce
que ça c'est une autre est très très
mauvaise attitude avoir parce que ça va
renforcer le camp chacun va pas se
conforter dans l'idée que
notre camp et le boucan et que le camp
opposé est vraiment faux méchant en soi
de nouvelles et ça je pense que ça ne
dépend pas de société très général parce
qu'au final cas typiquement sur les
sujets politiques à londres sur la
redistribution des richesses
au final tout le monde veut à peu près
la même chose qu'il ya des consensus en
société ce rôle a dit pas vraiment avec
une science exacte mais globalement il
ya vraiment un succès étonnant à la fois
gerrish veulent d'entre elles après une
étude de piété et de bretagne à nantes
avant les riches veulent quelques mois
d'une certaine manière que l'argent soit
mieux redistribuer et mes pauvres sont
conscients que les inégalités ou en tout
cas pense que les inégalités de richesse
sont souhaitables dans société soit aux
états unis ou en france
c'est très surprenant en fait sur le
pape dans une sélection de pièces on est
tous d'accord et je pense que la raison
les bleus l'ont tous d'accord il ya des
petites différences mais elle s'est dit
qu'en sont négligeables par rapport aux
différences entre les opinions des gens
sont ni viable par rapport à la
différence entre ce qu'ils veulent
globalement et l'état actuel de nos
ordis équipe de reichel en société et du
coup on a tous envie que ça aille dans
le même sens de certains cas pas on pas
de méchants de mauvais dans cette
histoire mais le tous à peu près la même
chose sauf que je pense que lui dédie ce
nom scientifique est l'une des raisons
est libre critique
l'une des raisons majeures pour laquelle
on n'arrive pas à mettre en évidence ce
consensus parce que dès qu'on parle de
redistribution des richesses
les uns s'identifier à un parti
politique
donc moi ceux qui vont s'identifier aux
partis politiques de mac quand vont dire
que le libre échange de ces importants
et la liberté c'est important est ce
qu'ils vont s'identifier aux partis de
gauche comme ces deux mille enfants
publiquement à vous dire que la
redistribution déchets sera épaulé faire
c'est super info les protéger et la
discussion dation arrêter la vallée voir
une d'opposition alors qu'il y a
d'accord il ya un consensus global mais
on arrive à faire émerger désaccord est
un des deux camps qui s'opposent
par qui sont d'accord ça c'est vraiment
tous les méfaits de l'houphouétisme à
mon sens ce genre de truc je pense que
tous déjà arrivé quand il essayait de
débattre une heure avec des gens super
énervé au bout de la table et puis tout
à coup au bout d'une heure sont en fait
tous d'accord sur tout cas mais la
situation fait que comme le sujet est
qui on va mettre en avant d'abord à
notre désaccord et malheureusement les
cas où on se rend compte qu'on est en
fait d'accord ce n'est pas forcément
majoritaire quand même l'impression que
bien souvent en fait on est d'accord
mais comme on parle dogmatique on
cherche à vous montrer remettre en avant
un autre désaccord et ça c'est dommage
parce que du coup les consensus qui
existe ils ne sont pas mis en avoir pas
fait tout ça pour dire que je pense que
partager les commentaires débiles que
l'on reçoit c'est une très très très
mauvaise idée
dans ce fossile de cours sur plusieurs
pas forcément ceux qu'on reçoive ce
qu'on voit passer moquer de ceux qui est
débile chaud que c'est une très très
mauvaise habitude que on appris parce
que la planète nous pousse à faire ça va
et une autre sphère lee tube fait ça a
du sens car youtube et twitter font ça
du coup on a pris l'habitude de faire ça
et je pense que c'est vraiment très très
mal et il faut arrêter de partager les
commentaires stupides parce que l'un
faire c'est de la stupidité n'est pas
d'intelligence
ce n'est pas en vous montrant de choses
stupides que vous montrez que vous êtes
en pigeant pas du tout bien souvent
malheureusement je trouve que en fait se
moquer des trucs stupides et en fait
également tout aussi stupide et du coup
vous vous demandez peut être comment moi
je réagis maintenant à des commentaires
débiles sur ma chaîne j'ai supprimé
voilà c'est façon de donner beaucoup
moins d'importance à ce qui je pense ne
mérite aucune importance plutôt que de
leur donner l'importance plutôt que
d'écrire une importance à ce genre de
messages en les partageant
sur les réseaux sociaux plus globalement
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de se moquer
des trucs débiles et surtout quand on
s'intéresse à ce que pense aux cantons
repose et qu'on cherche cependant pas
rejeté ces arguments
je pense qu'il faut absolument que
chercher à radoter des arguments les
plus insidieux en fait du camp opposé
parce que c'est comme ça qu'ils élèvent
le niveau du débat qu'on rend le débat
intéressant et on peut d'ailleurs
concédé des choses pourront reposer un
peu c'est comme ça c'est qu'on peut se
rendre compte aussi de consensus en fait
qui existe
partagez l'intelligence pas la stupidité
ça s'était mal forcément ça vaut ce que
ça vaut vous invite en débattre dans les
commentaires
mais sachant que les arguments qui
consiste à rejeter la stupidité
d'arguments opposée sur les prix